so I actually want to start here uh
because I I I find this interesting um
and there's a lot of outrage over this
here's uh Forbes
article two bills that could loosen
child labor laws are moving through the
Florida legislature making it easier for
teens to work longer hours in more
dangerous jobs as the state battles a
labor shortage which some critics say is
made worse by a Crackdown on
undocumented immigrant workers um a uh a
Florida bill that was passed by a state
senate committee Wednesday could allow
16 and 17 year olds to work on
construction project s in residential
areas as long as the projects are lower
than 6 fet a revision from the original
text that sought to allow the teens to
work on roofs uh a separate bill called
employment and curfew of minors is
moving through the State House
Legislative committee and uh intends to
allow 16 to 17 year olds to work up to
40 hours a week 30 is the current law
even when school's in session the latter
Bill introduced by Republican state
representative Linda Cheney would force
60 and 7 year olds to be given the same
amount of breaks as adults a change to
the current law which requires 30 minute
breaks every four hours um
so everybody would get the same amount
of breaks in that case um so that's kind
of the law and a lot of problems with
the way that this is reported and I mean
we'll kind of get into it but first of
all force force there's there's no bill
that's forcing any there's no bill
forcing 16 and 17y olds to go get jobs
like that's not that's not it's not
forced
labor um but what the bill would do is
it would make it a little bit easier for
um people under the for for you know for
people under the age of
for kids to get jobs um and the media is
lamenting that in large part I mean they
get they give the game away right right
at the top they're lamenting it
primarily because it will take jobs away
from illegal immigrants our kids getting
jobs will take jobs away from you we
can't have that that's not fair it's not
fair if our if our own children can have
jobs because then that means that uh you
know uh some 35-year-old illegal
immigrant is not supposed to be in a
first place won't be able to get one um
anyway so here's a here's a clip that
went viral of one Republican talking
about um the need for the bill and and
people were upset about what he says
here I mean you tell me if this is
upsetting let's listen we've been
weakening our society uh since before my
time uh I you know I started working at
like 13 years old a full-time job I
wrestled I played every sport you can
imagine so the idea that that they can't
afford to to have these kids do this is
is an anomaly for me in my mind if
there's an issue with inflation we
should address that with with the
federal government not not the State of
Florida so I appreciate you running this
bill uh you guys continue doing the
great work and and help change your
youth the youth uh out there to have
them start working full-time thanks
great rep barington you're uh okay so
that's supposed to be some kind of
outrageous statement from the Florida
State Rep the left is really mad about
it um in fact there there's been on
social media a general leftist Panic
recently over child labor quote unquote
child labor in um in uh uh in Florida
and and elsewhere and they're very upset
that child labor is making a comeback
according to them and I put quotes
around child labor because that
obviously has a certain like when when
they use that phrase it brings to mind
even though it's technically like if a
if a kid has a job like a job even if
they're working behind a cash register
the job is labor and uh and they are
kids if they under the age of 18
um but the the phrase child labor is
supposed to bring to mind like kids
working in mindes and on Factory
assembly lines for 18 hours a day that
that's that's what it that's what that
phrase kind of brings to mind and that's
why they uh use it but anyway they're
they're saying that child labor is
making a comeback very upset about it um
here's another video in this vein so
somebody posted this clip of a kid
working at a Burger King I don't know
who took this video I mean the kid's
just working there and somebody comes in
and takes a video of them uh and this
video got like 5 million views a lot of
people very upset about it uh saying you
know this poor kid is like he's
basically a slave this is terrible um
and and uh we blurred his face because
he's a kid but but here it
is what are your specials uh we have a 2
for S on our rou chicken sandwiches and
a two for five on our W Juniors and our
BK RS and also you can get six cookies
for
250 um I just have one cheeseburger to
go please one cheeseburger is that all
for you today that would be all all
right that would be
$211
$211 it's $1.99 plus tax ma'am I'm sorry
cheeseburgers at McDonald's were used to
be 69 cents when I worked there for my
first
job
oh hello
hello what if you want any right over
there wow how horrifying I mean how
terrible this kid is better at his job
and provides better customer service
than like 99% of fast food employees
that that's the only bad thing I see
here that's the it's that and also that
the woman is hassling what are you
hassling the kid for about the price of
the hamburger what what is he gonna do
about it um it's the only thing that's
like shocking and appalling about that
video is that this kid is like his first
job he's probably been working there for
you know it couldn't have been very long
and he's significantly better than
almost everybody you encounter who who's
working at a fast food place outside of
Chick-fil-A that's Burger King like by
Burger King standards my God this this
this kid should be the general manager
of that store that is that is because
that would be that that's that's above
average customer service for a
Chick-fil-A but you put that at at
Burger King I we've talked about this
before the the the customer service of
Burger King is it's aggressively it's
like almost violently angry when you
walk and you walk in they start throw
they throw like shoes at you as soon as
you walk in the door they just they hate
you so much for being there the fact
that this kid's got got a smile on his
face and he's interacting um by Burger
King standards that is he's employee of
the year the globally already well if
you're like me there's not a day that
goes by that you don't call or text
someone you care about I'm constantly on
the phone gabbing away everyone knows it
my friends up P talk are making it
easier and more affordable to connect
with the most important people in your
life pure talk gives you phenomenal
coverage on America's Most Dependable 5G
Network it's the same coverage you know
and love but for half the price of the
other guys with unlimited plans starting
at just 20 bucks a month the average
family saves almost $1,000 a year as a
veteran-owned company Pur talk raised
$10 million towards veteran debt last
year alone what's more Pur talks
customer service team is located right
here in the US and can help you make the
switch in as little as 10 minutes so I
challenge you to stand with a company
that champion Champions your values
today and also provides great service so
go to Pur talk.com Walsh and right now
you'll save an additional 50% off your
first month that's Pur talk.com Walsh to
save on wireless with a company that you
can be proud of uh and you can be proud
to spend your money with and support
again Pur talk.com Walsh a few things in
general about
this uh child labor laws were enacted
back in the early 20th century
when you had as as alluded to you know
you had kids working in coal mines and
doing dangerous factory jobs where they
were getting fingers and limbs chopped
off and that sort of thing uh the idea
was to protect kids from that and we did
it's good that we did um well here we
are 100 years later and the kinds of
jobs that most kids do or would do are
very different okay kids now if they
have a job are standing behind a cash
register in a temperature controlled
building for a few hours a day with
lunch breaks and breaks and everything
else it's not the coal mines you know
this is not a 12-year-old on the factory
assembly line for 16 hours with no break
so what exactly is the problem what is
the problem can someone explain to me if
you watch that video and you you say
it's terrible why is it terrible what is
wrong with what's happening there um you
know I had my first real job I say real
job like my first W2 job when I was
14 I actually started working when I was
12 I was mowing lawns for cash but I got
an actual job at 14 at had a Snowball
Stand and it was great I made money I
got free snowballs uh I I I I learned
some basic skills I got some work
experience um I was doing something
productive with my
time what's the downside how is that a
problem keep something in mind here uh
CH quote unquote child labor which is
like like kids are doing labor which is
doing some kind of work of some kind
that's been the rule for human
civilization sense forever before the
Industrial Age It's you get these these
dumb leftists who pretend that this look
at what happens in
capitalism meanwhile over in China which
is not a capitalist system they've got
they have seveny olds you know making
iPhones um but this has been the rule
for human civilization since forever
before the industrial Industrial Age
kids kids would work the farm with their
you know with their families they would
do chores around the house real chores
you know real work and um and now if
they have a job it's probably work in a
Drive-Thru or whatever so this is not
new the only thing that's new is this
notion popular in some Corners that kids
should not do any kind of work at
all until they are into adulthood until
they graduate college you know now you
do have plenty of of uh of uh scenarios
where you've got like a 23y old adult
who has never done any kind of work ever
so the it's not just like that's not an
outlier that's you got millions of
people in their early 20s Who come out
of college and they've never done any
form of work
ever um that is what is extraordinarily
modern and Western it's very very new
and um it's obviously totally
counterproductive in every conceivable
way um what would you rather have kids
do like this kid at Burger King would
you would it be what's a better of his
time is it better for him to be at home
playing video games for seven hours a
day is it better would you like is it
better if he's sitting on the couch
scrolling Tik Tok is that like if you
don't want kids to work any kind of job
what would you prefer for them to be
doing
instead uh it's pretty clear that
whatever they be doing instead it's it
wouldn't be as productive or as good for
them as good for the the the child as
the experience he can get at a job
provided the job is safe and it's not
and it's you're you're not uh um you
know you're not treating the kids like
slave labor provided that's not
happening which it isn't at Burger
King uh then I don't you know it's it's
absurd something else to
consider too is is like why have kids
always historically done some kind of
work well because because yeah it's good
for them it helps them gain skill and
experience and maturity but also because
their families needed it so if you lived
at a on a farm in the year 1752
you needed your children to help they
had to it was a necessity you it was a
survival necessity everyone had to
contribute you know um and uh and and
and the point is that part of the
advantage of a child working is the
child is then contributing in a real and
valuable way to the family so um if we
come in and say no no kids allowed to
work makes us feel bad to see the poor
little guy behind the cash register well
now in many cases you've just created an
additional Financial strain on the
family uh when a kid is 14
15 and uh has a
job you know makes some money and if you
you know maybe maybe that new pair of
shoes that he wants he can buy with with
with the money that he's earned that
sort of thing like this this really
matters to families it's a big uh help
and we've just got this idea now that it
just it can't be allowed you know you
can't have anyone under 18 in in a
family who's contributing in any way
financially to the household it's a
totally it it's just it's the kind of
thought process people engage in when
they're when they're not think there's
actually no thought process at all it's
just like this instinctive modern
reaction to something if You' like to
see what else I have to say you can
access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wallow Twitter page hope to see you
there God speed